ya se tiñe de morado miles de mujeres se
tomaron las calles de la capital parís
para reivindicar el fin de la violencia
sexual contra las mujeres y pedir al
gobierno francés medidas más
contundentes para terminar con esta
endémica problemática
en cuanto a los salarios la forma de
vestir de ser la forma de mirar tenemos
que exagerar nuestra apariencia sexual
izando nos ser mujer no es sólo ser
sexualizada va más allá no somos sólo
objetos sexuales
porque estoy aquí por muchas razones que
se pueden resumir en una palabra sexismo
como mujer como persona considerada como
tal lo sufro demasiado mis amigas
también y estoy harta pueden ser
pequeños detalles y actos mucho más
violentos
los colectivos feministas enarbolaron
emblemas contra la desigualdad de género
y la impunidad en los casos de violencia
machista en francia- unas 220.000
mujeres son víctimas de violencia de
género y 101 mujeres han sido asesinadas
por sus parejas en lo que va de año para
algunas activistas se deben revisar los
protocolos de las instituciones que
juzgan y tratan estos casos
y lo que queremos hacer es formar ante
todo formar formar al personal policial
para que pueda responder adecuadamente a
las víctimas de la violencia de género y
sexual formar al personal jurídico para
que pueda dictar órdenes de protección
es formar al personal sanitario para que
pueda detectar la violencia porque
desgraciadamente la mayoría de las
víctimas no hablan de ello que unas
marchas que preceden al 25 de noviembre
día mundial para la eliminación de la
violencia contra la mujer con grandes
manifestaciones en todo el mundo